welcome back jill darren was one of the
original cast members of the real
housewives of new york so she is no
stranger to the spotlight but jill has
always had a passion for fashion and
design and as she continues to grow her
business in the home decor space and the
fashion industry she joins us to tell us
about her new endeavors hey jill
hi julian how are you i'm good jill and
jillian i feel like we're meant to be
friends i know we're both wearing black
and white today
we're on the same page here
congratulations on everything
yes yes
congrats on everything you've been
working on i was looking through your
social media pages and looking at your
website all of your design is so
beautiful let's talk a little bit just
about everything you're up to and i hear
you have a vegas tie-in
i do i feel terrible that i'm not at the
vegas show but due to covet and uh the
you know the varian and i take i'm with
my parents down in florida i just felt
it would be irresponsible for me to fly
there with everything that's going on
right now although my nephew jonathan
lives in vegas so um i know he's
watching today so i'm excited about that
but we are at the show for anybody who's
not there yet uh jill's aaron ruggs is
in i'm not even sure what building but
it's a pretty big presence we've been
there uh for i think about five years
now and the business has just grown
tremendously and it's really exciting
that we've expanded jill's aaron home to
cover so many other areas because now we
have throws we have blankets
everything's available online and we
even have furniture making that you put
together yourself at home which is very
convenient for a lot of people who don't
want to go out shopping so they can shop
online
yeah we're seeing some of the photos
here of everything from the furniture to
the rugs and everything is just so
beautiful so fun and vibrant what would
you say is kind of the inspiration
behind your your designs
it's a good question jillian it's
affordable luxury because i myself um
growing up the way i did i'm always
looking for a bargain i mean lomans if
anybody from the east coast remembers
you know was the bargain place where you
get designer clothes for less which now
became so many other stores i think it
was embedded in me to um find the best
of everything at a good value and you
don't have to overpay for furniture and
you don't have to overpay for rugs and
what's great about jill's aaron rugs is
that they're pet proof or stain proof if
you want to call it um everything comes
out of that pretty much so i think
that's why it's gained so much momentum
over the years because people tell
people that they have these outdoor rugs
indoor rugs that don't stain so and
they're very affordable they start at 49
and go up to about 500 for the biggest
ones so you can imagine what value that
is well jill you're speaking my language
i love a good bargain thank you so much
for sharing everything with us and real
quick i know you run a lot of businesses
but people can find you and all of your
items on social media and your website
right
absolutely jilzarin.com and jill and
ali.com before you leave i just want to
show you we have these manifestation
candles with crystals so for this time
of year if you have things that you hope
and dream for or just want to make
better about yourself this one is less
is more which we can all do decluttering
these inspiration candles have been
doing phenomenal on jillianally.com i
love that i'm gonna have to get me one
of those jill thank you so much hope to
see you in vegas next time jc i'll send
it over to you thank